i when i was reading your book there
were it was fascinating all the way
through there were certain moments that
particularly piqued my interest in
particularly when you touched on bpd
borderline personality disorder would
you like to go and talk about that a
little bit
um
yeah so borderline personality disorder
um
there is this idealization and
devaluation that's one that's one major
component of it and i'm familiar with
bpd because i've made
i had a couple close friends with bpd
and i have a very very close family
member who has bpd
and there are funny stories to tell
about her that maybe i'll leave
they're funny now in retrospect at the
time they were not very funny just for
anyone who doesn't know at all what
borderline personality disorder is just
start from the very start from the very
beginning so borderline personality
disorder is called borderline
personality disorder actually because it
was unclear if it was a personality
disorder or a more significant disorder
right they were unclear about where it
actually fell so it's not at all like
dissociative identity disorder or
multiple personalities it's actually a
disorder where you have very volatile
relationships these people often have
problems with drugs and alcohol they
have problems keeping any kind of
romantic relationship and they also
vacillate very quickly between
idealizing and devaluing their uh
partners this is someone who looks up to
you like your
god
one minute and then just think you're
the worst person in the world the next
day yes and why was the wonder why those
people struggle to keep a relationship
yeah um so a big part of it is
volatility yeah but um
if you if you define borderline
personality disorder some people would
argue with me and say it's not more
common in women than men i think it's
much more common in women than men if
you want to say that men have an equal
rate of it you have to define it i think
quite differently
so i'll just talk about women's
borderline personality disorder but i
think all women have a touch of this and
i think it's kind of like hyper training
so you can be incredibly reinforcing to
somebody one minute these women escalate
romantic involvement often very very
quickly and like i dated a woman who had
borderline personality disorder and
there was just
so many amazing things about her like
she
knew everything about me she had so many
pictures of me in her room we were
university together that people knew
where i was because excuse me for me she
knew all my preferences all my favorite
things if i told her a story once she
would remember it forever right she had
an amazing social memory but i took her
to a party once right it was like a
halloween party around this time of year
many years ago and um she was just
wearing like a coat and lingerie and i
literally talked to somebody else for
five minutes and she left and started
walking down a
not dangerous part of texas but a dark
part of texas in the middle of the night
in just lingerie and a coat
in order to punish me basically for
talking to somebody else for diverting
my attention for five minutes and
women who have borderline personality
disorder
also um more likely to
do what's called parasuicide to say that
they are going to attempt suicide or
threaten to attempt suicide so
what i talk about in in the book is
basically that this is like a like
training and overdrive right it's
these women can be they're really good
at remembering your preferences they
know what's uniquely reinforcing to you
sex is something that's uniquely
reinforcing to men they know how to use
that they know how to use their
attractiveness they're incredibly
compelling in many ways but they can
also be incredibly punitive and
the family member that i have is amazing
amazing at figuring out where the
jugular is of somebody what is like the
worst thing that you could say to
somebody that they're going to be
thinking about for months or years and
this is something else that they're
really really good at and it's it's an
incredible it's kind of a superpower but
in the sense that you know in x-men or
any of these other movies you see some
people who have superpowers use them for
good and some people use them for evil i
do think that women have this ability
and if you know about what you're trying
to do with it you can use it to really
strengthen and improve your
relationships rather than make somebody
else miserable and control them
completely but it sounds as if there's
traits of narcissism there as well
in that there's similarities between the
two have i got that completely wrong
i've learned to read it
narcissism there's there's often a
commonality with narcissism i think
narcissism gets defined so broadly now
that i actually don't know
you know there's all these videos on
youtube and things about like how to
deal with a narcissist and narcissist is
kind of just code now a psychology code
for like shitty person
shitty person
yeah so narcissism yeah there is some
some degree of it and then there's this
thing called fragile narcissism which
even expands the definition further
where you're like okay well somebody who
thinks really highly of themselves but
sometimes also doesn't think highly
themselves that's that's kind of
everybody so there is an aspect of it
there in that they think that they're so
important that somebody else should give
over all their attention and energy and
resources to them so i would say that is
actually accurate yeah and one thing i
wanted to to deal with before we wrap up
the interview you talked about the
differences between men and women in in
some of these areas
manipulating other people or that's a
negative word but influence on other
people let's say uh one of the
experiments you talk about is that a
four-year study i think of couples found
that if the woman was less forgiving at
the end of that four year period the man
was essentially better trained let's say
but it wasn't replicated on the other
side if the if the man was less
forgiving and you used punishment and
whatever the woman didn't tend to change
yeah so what what is that all about and
maybe you know since since the book is
gendered
towards women uh what are some tips for
men for how to behave with their
romantic partner if she's female okay so
forgiveness is just the suspension of
punishment so anger
forgiveness is just when you stop being
angry and it's a form of reinforcement
in that in the same ways if i was just
hitting you over the head i don't know i
keep looking there
it's just hitting you overhead and then
i stopped it would be reinforcing even
though me not hitting you overhead right
now is not reinforcing i know why you
keep looking at him because uh
out of the two of us in your mind he's
the only potential available romantic
party
because you think i'm gay for some
reason diana so let's go we'll go back
to this one i thought that constant when
in the last interview i kept saying like
well you don't have to worry about this
concept yeah i was like
and i remember at the time i was like a
gay jewish russian can you tell me about
how you sought asylum
you poor poor things and you see this is
the way they're going for the jugular
and i was thinking for like a month
after that what are the vibes that i'm
sending off here well you said my
partner francis and then i i met francis
you guys never do that again
you guys should do something for the
female gays right now
but anyway uh yes i did totally think
constantine was gay and then yeah
the partner thing is is super weird
um so uh hitting somebody over there had
forgiveness yes so in this long-term
study they found that a woman who
whose forgiveness increased over time
had a partner whose conscientiousness
increased over time that's a very very
fancy way of saying that
essentially women were using punishment
to change their partner's personalities
and conscientiousness is a major
personality characteristic that you
would want in a husband
conscientiousness means that he's going
to do things that he said he was going
to do he's going to feel bad when he
didn't do the things that he said he was
going to do and he's also going to be
attentive to your needs those are all
conscientiousness things and so even
though it's unclear how much environment
can change personality
it is interesting that there's actually
not more studies about how much wives
and husbands can change one another's
personalities so in this study they
actually found that women were changing
men's personalities their husbands
personalities more than vice versa and
that men's forgiveness had no influence
on women's conscientiousness now this
could be a novel modern thing you know
it could be that
men had more control over their wives in
the past and that dynamic has flipped or
it could be that women are using these
more sophisticated methods in order to
change personality and that the
you know the the method that a man would
have had at his disposal which is
threats has become morally frowned upon
right to to put it lightly and so that
could be it i'm not really sure why but
it does seem that
women are
better at this particular skill in my
view than men are
[Music]